this is a dream come true I never never
imagined that I would be honored I'm
just so thrilled and of all the honors
that I have received I think this is the
most significant reneging meant a lot to
me a lot I knew about it I knew it was
academically superior they didn't have a
football team was brains not brawn and
each faculty member taught like they
were the only one giving assignments and
all I never worked so hard in school in
all my life as I did when I was in
library school here but it paid off it
really paid off because I became a
excellent researcher and the two and a
half years that I worked at crow calling
or publishing company in New York City I
didn't live any reference question savvy
me or bother me because I knew I could
answer it I could research it and get
the answer answer or I knew where I
could find the answer so I got a
superior superior library a school
education here at them Carnegie
Institute of Technology I loved
Pittsburgh and I and my colleagues were
very very nice to me there were only it
was during the war years and there were
only 18 of us in the in the class and
five of us including TC Weaver for
Maggie Murph and the other girls were
from Indiana and Ohio and surrounding
areas here but the five of us round
robins letters we kept in touch all the
years and there are only two of us now
who are living and we keep in touch and
we had three reunions we had a reunion
here in Pittsburgh and I never will
forget the young man who was videotaping
he was just astounded when we told him
that we were paid $2,400 a year
remember this was 1944-45 but the men
got more money than we did they got
$1,000 a year more than we did simply
because there were men I did my practice
work in New York City at the Schomburg
of the 135th Street Branch Library and I
always just described myself as being
the most occupationally suited person
that I knew I loved my work I loved it
whatever you do do the best you can and
don't leave them any stone unturned and
it's really really very fortunate but I
think even with the new technology which
is wonderful I think that you need to be
able to dig back at primary sources to
research I think you need both things I
think you know technology and I think
you need the hard book digging in even
in old newspapers or something up to
your elbows and print you may need to do
the best you can work hard and and don't
give up
finding answers to things